sur mon coeur il ya un badge sur lequel
et est écrit je suis bénévole
demandez moi pourquoi je suis bénévole
demandez moi pourquoi parce que en étant
bénévole en faisant du bénévolat j'ai
constaté que cela me rendait heureuse ça
fait une quinzaine d'années vingtaine
d'années que je pratique entre
guillemets le bénévolat essentiellement
associatif et caritatif essentiellement
mais dans la famille mon épouse a fait
du bénévolat
on a deux enfants ma fille fait du
bénévolat depuis qu'elle a 18 ans
aujourd'hui elle fait du bénévolat
depuis trois ans elle est d'aider plus
petite qu'elle a son cours de
gymnastique une fois par semaine elle va
avoir le baccalauréat donc juste après
son diplôme
donc dans l'année scolaire qui va
arriver l'albien va pas continuer
l'école elle va partir en en mission
humanitaire
notre garçon a créé sa première
association à 17 ans et demi
alors bon plus tôt dans l'aisne le
bénévolat culturel il l'organisé
festival de rock
le prochain aura lieu début septembre
donc le bénévolat vraiment nourrit notre
vie et notre garçon a eu 20 ans au mois
de septembre dernier
et puis on s'est dit avec mon épouse
comment on va marquer son 20e
anniversaire
il a une voiture qui n'est pas fameuse
hormis la couleur qui a approximative
n'est pas très belle c'est l'arrière
malheur devant c'est pas fameux non plus
et toute personne normalement constituée
enfin tout parent se dit bon quand même
on va acheter une nouvelle voiture au
moins la rangée cela et puis on a
préféré lui donner l'argent et avec cet
argent on pensait on l'invitait en tous
les cas aller passer une semaine à rome
et puis finalement à noël dernier nous a
dit ban avec cet argent je n'ai pas mis
dans la bagnole je les paris pour les as
rome mais j'aimerais bien aller pendant
quinze jours en mission humanitaire au
bénin c'est ce qu'il a fait le bénévolat
nous rend heureux
je travaille dans un lycée à lorient je
ne suis pas enseignant je vais pas mal
de choses en cet établissement scolaire
et le 28 mars 2013
on a fait ceci 2276 personnes dans sept
établissements sur le terrain de sport à
faire le plus grand sourire humain
jamais réalisée en europe rien les yeux
et la bouche c'est 500 personnes des
jeunes des adultes
les enseignants des élèves et surtout on
avait invité tous les bénévoles du pays
lorient à venir nous soutenir
il y avait qu'une centaine
d'associations représentées ce jour-là
et au bas de ce smiley géant
une grande banderole bénévolat égale
sourire quand je fais du bénévolat
j'apporte du sourire à la personne
pujade mais en même temps je reçois
énormément de souris en main propre vie
et c'est ce qu'on a ici d'enseigner à
nos jeunes c'est vrai que dans cet
établissement mon mon rôle est et 2
d'invités vraiment la jeunesse à faire
du bénévolat à s'engager auprès des
autres
depuis quelques années effectivement le
bénévolat nourri ma vie j'étais bénévole
à emmaüs à emmaüs qui reçoit des
cabossés de la vie
un jour j'étais assis lors du déjeuner à
côté d'une une amie chez emmaüs on
appelle les bénévoles des amis qu'est ce
que c'est beau j'étais assise à côté
d'elle et monique me dis-je emmaüs m'a
sauvé la vie
quelle phrase en fait elle m'a expliqué
que son mari était mort précipitamment
d'une mort violente
monique m'a dit que le viol avait le
sauver sa vie elle l'a étaient
sollicités sans arrêt par sa voisine qui
était bénévole depuis bien longtemps
emmaüs moning ne voulait pas aller à
emmaüs
et pourtant à force d'être sollicitée
elle a fini par dire bon moi je vais
venir une fois
monique est venu une fois elle est
revenue le lendemain elle est revenue le
surlendemain et la semaine suivante et
les semaines suivantes et les années
suivantes
emmaüs lui a sauvé la vie au lycée où je
travaille
on a mis en place une maraude auprès des
sans abri dont tous les mardis soir de
début septembre jusqu'à début juillet
tous les mardis soirs avec des jeunes de
l'établissement plus ces bénévoles qui
viennent de l'extérieur des enseignants
on va à la rencontre des gens qui sont
dans la rue c'est ce qu'on appelle une
maraude
on apporte personnes qui sont dans la
rue des vêtements des couvertures de la
nourriture des boissons chaudes
mais surtout ce qu'on leur apporte c'est
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de fraternité
et un regard qui est autre un regard
différent qu'on ne pose jamais sur ces
personnes qui sont à la rue des
personnes en fragilité
voilà c'est ce qui anime ma vie tout au
long de de l'année dans le lycée où je
travaille la maraude et l'inde l'une des
composantes de ma vie le bénévolat rend
ma vie heureuse est quelqu'un qui a
écrit beaucoup sur le bénévolat
mais on le sait pas jean jacques goldman
dans la vie j'ai eu plusieurs métiers
notamment celui de l'interviewer de
personnalité et je vous avoue que quand
on m'avait proposé de rencontrer jean
jacques goldman
il ya très longtemps un bon celui qui a
écrit quand la musique est bonne bonne
bonne ou quand la musique sonne sonne
sonne ça me parlait pas vraiment un
c'était parce qu'il me passionnait le
plus j'ai appris à le connaître
également elle est très engagée auprès
des personnes qui sont en fragilité bien
évidemment vous connaissez son
engagement auprès des restaurants du
coeur avec des notamment il a
écrit cette fameuse chanson sur les
où il dit ceci
aujourd'hui on n'a plus de droit et
d'avoir faim ni d'avoir froid dépasser
les chacun pour soi quand je pense à toi
je pense à moi c'est incroyable cette
phrase quand je pense à toi je pense à
moi un philosophe psychologue chercheur
américain alan luxe a fait une étude il
ya quelques années et il a demandé à
trois mille volontaires de leur donner
le sentiment qu'ils ont eue après avoir
effectué une action bénévole 3000
volontaires 90% de ces volontaires ont
dit qu'après avoir effectué cette action
bénévole
eh bien il se sentait bien ben oui faire
du bien fait du bien à soi même c'est
vraiment l'enseignement qui l'attiré de
c'est de cette étude et quand vous
saurez que le bénévolat rend moins
dépressifs que les personnes qui sont
bénévoles sont moins un sujet tish
à la maladie d'alzheimer quand on sait
que les bénévoles de façon générale et
vieillissent beaucoup mieux ça donne
comme une petite envie est bénévole et
ça ne coûte rien ça coûte du temps
alors vous me direz oui moi je n'ai pas
le temps je vous citais emmanuel faber
emmanuel faber si le pdg de danone
je pense que cet homme là n'a pas le
temps il a certes des loisirs mais il
n'a pas les mêmes annuel faber consacre
une partie de ses temps libres au
bénévolat et c'est me raconter une
histoire qui se déroule en inde pour
ceux qui ont déjà été en inde vous le
savez les trains sont toujours bombay et
en avant dans les trains il y avait
tellement peu de place que les gens
allaient également sur les wagons
un conte ou une histoire je ne fais pas
c'est un monsieur qui est assise sur
l'un des wagons un moment donné il ya sa
sandale qui s'envole
qu'est-ce qui fait automatiquement il
prend cette deuxième sandales et la
balance son voisin à côté 10 mai un peu
foulée il explique que sa première
centrale n'étant plus là
5600 verra plus du tout dans la vie donc
autant balance un deuxième scandale à la
personne qui pourra récupérer la finale
pour moi c'est du bénévolat
cette action certes la générosité
on sait également du bénévolat philippe
pozzo di borgo dont je vous parlerai
tout à l'heure j'aurais préalablement
j'aurais aimé vous montrer tous ses
engagements ses qualités qu'on peut
découvrir qu'on peut recevoir en faisant
du bénévolat se valoriser et des
rencontres et être heureux utile
confiance en soi partager
l'autre acquérir des compétences tout
cela c'est gratuit il suffit juste
effectivement d'un peu de temps donc
donné le peu que l'on peut il s'appelle
philippe pozzo di borgo
vous le connaissez sans doute c'est
l'une des personnalités les plus
extraordinaires qu'on a en france
il a écrit un très beau livre qui
s'appelle toi et moi j'y crois
c'est son histoire qui a inspiré le film
intouchables philippe est devenu une
personne proche et philippe dans ce
livre il insiste bien auprès des
personnes qui sont en fragilité auprès
des personnes qui sont handicapés il dit
à ces personnes aller vers les autres
aller vers les plus cabossés de la vie
on viendra pas vous vous cherchez vous
qui êtes en fragilité donc aller vers
les autres
combien vous verrez que cela vous fera
du bien d'aller vers l'autre et dans ce
très beau livre il dit ceci il faut
faire la pub de l'autre quelle phrase
étonnante quelle phrase magnifique il
faut faire la pub de l'autre dans les
maraudes que l'on fait auprès des sans
abri je me souviens d'avoir accueilli 1
cécile dans mon bureau
cécile est une adolescente en pleine
croissance elle a quelques difficultés
il a mal au dos et caetera et cécile
un jour elle vient me voir jugement
comment ça va et aidera puis elle dit oh
là là ça va pas tellement j'ai mal au
dos et judy à ses fils
je suis sûr que quand tu fais des
maraudes tu n'as pas mal au dos vous
savez quand on est étonné un peu on fait
un rictus on se dit tiens comment il
fait je suis allé dans son esprit non je
ne suis pas bien son esprit je savais
que c'était le cas et cécile
effectivement n'a pas mal au dos quand
elle fait des maraudes auprès des sans
abri c'est pour ça que j'invite tous les
élèves dans notre établissement a bien
m'écouter à dire même la personne la
plus égoïste de la terre même si elle
n'a pas le souci de l'autre tant pis en
faisant du bien à l'autre on se fait du
bien à soi même
alors autant que pour ce message pour
les égoïstes qu'ils soient entendus
donc oui oui si vous connaissez des
personnes qui ont ce qu'ils défaut et
bien inviter l'es1 faire du bénévolat
lorsque j'étais plus jeune
c'est rien quelques temps j'ai travaillé
à gérer dans l'association des parents
d'élèves de l'école de mes enfants et la
semaine dernière je leur ai demandé à
tous les deux ce qu'ils avaient pensé
lorsqu'il se des plus petits de mon
engagement dans leur école
jamais j'aurais pensé demander c'est te
poser des questions là donc
mais là il faut mener que l'on m'a
proposé de venir ici de parler du
bénévolat
je leur ai demandé ma fille et mon fils
je n'ai pas vu au moment au même moment
mon fils m'a dit c'était cool j'étais
fier ça m'a donné envie de faire du
bénévolat de m'engager ma fille le
lendemain dit à peu près la même chose
et la même phrase j'étais fier et ma
fille m'a dit une autre chose est de
madine en aidant l'école tu m'as aidé à
mieux travailler assez incroyable oui on
peut faire du bénévolat de n'importe
quelle manière ya plein de possibilités
sur du biennois
par exemple le don du sang certains
d'entre vous donnent leur sang moi je
les données une fois ça va monsieur sera
ou pas faire que moi faut donner votre
sang moi j'ai arrêté ce jour là il faut
donner votre sang vraiment pas faire
comme moi le bonheur est dans le don
c'est une phrase que j'aime beaucoup
donc on donne on donne
il ya un moment où on voudrait que
partager plusieurs choses et ya une
phrase que j'aime beaucoup qui est il
restera de toi ce que tu as donné c'est
un prêtre et poète finistériens qui dit
cette phrase d s'appelle michel le
scouarnec
il restera de toi ce que tu as donné mon
fils est animateur auprès d'enfants
c'est son boulot et il dit combien les
jeunes sont contents d'aider et c'est
vrai qu'il ya inclination naturelle chez
les jeunes pour aider autour de soi ce
n'est pas une question de culture ce
n'est pas une question de d'éducation
c'est naturel pourquoi en france on
n'applique pas beaucoup plus que cela
les jeunes à toutes ces actions de
générosité dans les écoles primaires
dans les collèges dans les lycées
j'ai ma mission est vrai que ce soit
partout en france
oui il restera de toi ce que tu as donné
il ya quelques jours le monde a fait
paraître un article
hallucinant dans lequel était écrit pour
faire valoriser les jeunes et
l'engagement auprès des jeunes
eh bien on propose des points
supplémentaires au baccalauréat il ya 25
mesures proposées par ces chercheurs
qu'ils ont proposé au ministre de l' de
la ville de la jeunesse et des sports et
des points supplémentaires
quelle belle idée on verra ce que cela
donnera en tout les cas j'aime
et que pour les futures élections
présidentielles il est quelqu'un qui ose
vous savez dans le débat entre deux
tours où il ya deux candidats face à
face oppose et jean rien que l'un des
deux dix mois président je voudrais que
dans les écoles primaires les écoles
maternelles les collèges les lycées on
favorise tous les actions de bénévolat
mois président j'inviterais mon ministre
de l'éducation à tout entreprendre pour
ce que effectivement cette possibilité
de gagner des points supplémentaires
lors des ces apps et bep les
baccalauréats et tous les autres examens
on puisse précisément gagner quelques
points supplémentaires peut-être un mois
président je ferai la pub de l'autre moi
président je rappellerai que on a tous
en nous des ressources naturelles pour
faire progresser les ressources humaines
mais bon j'ai beau être optimiste je
pense que je ne serai jamais président
en revanche j'avais trouvé les bons
slogans bénévolat la force tranquille
bénévolat yes we can et le bénévolat
c'est maintenant merci